[Música]
urubus pessoal bebidas é mais um vídeo e
hoje vou ensinar como fazer uma catana
usando folhas de papel com vocês têm
tiro por lá tutorial passo a passo pois
podem ser samurais como el então bora lá
pessoal do primeiro fundo branco foi o
maior encargo vai gastar para comprar
quase pra linha do centro quando acham
que não têm idade entre a linha em cada
extremidade da folha dobram por cima da
linha em cala e tem duas voltas até
chegar à linha do centro quem treinar
mesmo na linha sempre se é só fazer o
mesmo para outra parte com mel já tinha
feito uma espada usando este processo é
que já não era mais para matar essa
seria uma espada nossa pequenina e vocês
pediram para fazer uma maior que estou a
fazer é usar fita para aprender uma para
a outra convenção de uma fita
transparente todos foi colorida e ficar
sem tomar banho
desta maneira falar aquela espectro
lâmina afiada típico das cavernas até aí
que nós fazer mais uma parte mas a
diferença é que nesta partida se vão
deixar uma distância maior
isso porque para que depois você consiga
encaixar uma pata lâmina na outra quebra
de resto é tudo igual no centro-sul por
uma parte à outra e prender com fita
outra vez
vejo aqui uma lâmina é maior que a outra
e vamos fora para elano termina dentro
íntegra
não é difícil ficar muito só um kadim
temporada é muito vai proteger da manhã
a cair nela só perderam um querido fita
que aparta contas tendo voz custo mas
convém que vocês não façam isso enfiar
para não ser pega o são carlos só bola
aqui uma folha com se fosse uma rifa
consegue fazer dois tubinhos como este
mês pela minha grande um final prender
um tubinho a outros vocês quiserem podem
usar uma folha de jornal grande usuário
é um exemplo porque anulado e agora
impor também no outro uma parte explicar
mais papel caíra para ficar para a
ferrari
braga foi a mãe outra vez diz ter para
fazer a para transição entre é para o
punho e do leme até e quer uma coisa
fica para o dia mal não sei como é que
existe mas se vocês souberem deixando os
comentários aqui no final é só aprender
com fita a volta é perfumado que não era
preciso mas era só uma questão de
técnica
agora atenção nesta para fazer uma
espécie de estrelinha mas há aqui duas
diagonais pois duas linhas e em cruz
você só pode baixar o centro para
produzir mais fácil do que nesta parte
do desenho losango e no final é só
cortar usando é utilizado o pé mas com
cuidado vocês forem crianças peçam ajuda
o outro toque
vamos encaixar tudo isso pode estar
dentro ea partir da separação lado ao
outro
vai entender um pingo vosso gosto se
vocês quiserem um grande ou pequena
somente no estado está morais é o espaço
cento para opor as duas mãos e foi o que
eu fiz nesta sexta feira maior concerto
tendo assim elas aprender com fita e
encaixar todos vocês vocês quiserem eu
aconselho que vocês ponham colombo que
tinha no final para aprender tudo porque
se não fica tão fixo foi o que eu fiz
depois e não gostei muito trial e
prontos aos cabos ou fios perto o estado
se vocês gostaram mesmo chegou sozinha
voz favorita e se inscreva no canal que
estuda ajuda bastante na divulgação e
reposição do meu trabalho e claro
estiverem mais sugestões do projeto é só
deixar os comentários que eu agradeço
isso só um grande abraço e até a próxima
etapa ao ferro